what's the deal with airplane peanuts
go back a little bit and we'll be the
newscasters uh
you mean all right we're here at stennis
space center out here in mechamom
florida a very exciting day for all of
us here at cnn
getting to witness the
challenger the launch of the challenger
and he's really
getting up there huh theo yeah i think
we're at about um
sixty thousand
now these spaceships the new ones are
actually built with um
this new material that that makes them
so much more durable oh gosh so much
safer
and you know looks safe to me
oh no theo
oh joe oh my oh
jehovah that is
is that it's going in a couple
directions now
i don't think that was
i don't think that's what was supposed
to happen oh it's coming back it seems
like maybe they're no that's exactly
what's supposed to happen
kids this is this is what's supposed to
happen
they're coming back the challenger there
they are there's
somebody know with these like these
older ladies like you're being a [ __ ]
you're giving it away and it's like well
isn't getting a dinner and a movie more
horry yes you know isn't that way
weirder like hey i'm not gonna [ __ ] you
until the fifth date after you buy me 17
pieces of salmon that's way more
prostitution yeah shout out salmon
omega-3 is heart healthy good to keep
the heart up and cholesterol down join a
pandywandy elliott paige i'll call you
oh
elliott paige oh yeah why i mean
again
[Music]
all right oh [ __ ] if we say too much tim
dillon's gonna fall out of a rafter
let me see if i was jesus would i let
you in
oh my god dude no i mean because at the
door i'd be like bad friends
i'd be like yeah but that was just my
you know
what yeah earthly project
i know but but that was but it gave you
meaning and fun and life and i'll just
say wait get go
there's a line you're going to make me
wait in this [ __ ] there's already a
line you're at the front of the line i
know i just it's not forever to get up
here go off to the side bobby go off the
side i got to see who else is coming in
bobby no no bobby i waited in the line i
didn't even skip the line i could have
skipped the line and said hi to you it
doesn't matter dude i'm jesus i run the
[ __ ] thing i understand but
security
all right so they put it to the side
right get off from me
you're going downstairs you're making it
you're not going downstairs or you're
not watch now watch who else i let it
all right kevin specie come on come on
[Laughter]
one of the most jealous times i've ever
had in my life is when you and joey diaz
took elle's children to
where was his tummy at disneyland oh my
god we got the we got the vip pimp tour
can you even imagine just being in line
and seeing you guys rolling i'm gonna
tell you something when i go to
disneyland go for it if i turn around
and mickey mouse [ __ ] me in the ass and
i pay to 119 i get my money's worth i'll
tell you why you know you're not gonna
get blown up you know you're not gonna
fall off one of those [ __ ] rocks
that's true the place is [ __ ] clean
immaculate
not even a gum wrapper
and if something does happen to flawless
i know there's a little [ __ ] mexican
dude with a sweeper with mickey mouse
ears on that comes up right behind you
and pick it the [ __ ] up they don't [ __ ]
around at disneyland but then we became
friends and then um
what happened so then i got mad tv you
got my tv we went down to san diego
together
right you borrowed a bunch of i can
bring up [ __ ] right you brought up
you bought a bunch of money for pills
[Laughter]
yeah yeah would you do we ever go to
brothels together yes in mexico too
[Laughter]
we were at some type of
like social setting you know like a
barbecue like someone's
house party or something and i remember
that it was daytime and there's a group
of people
and
like somebody
had mentioned like a woman had come up
and
had walked away
and it was like that natural thing where
somebody first did like the eyes and
then someone was like jesus
man and you know like you said like i
wouldn't mind
whatever spend the night with her like
something fine to say
and then somebody else like kind of
tagged it with like no [ __ ] you know
blah blah blah and there was a guy there
i don't know i thought it was like
somebody you remember not a dog
i remember this is what you asked me
about yeah and then he was like
that guy was like i
wouldn't mind [ __ ] her until she
shits
in the bed or something we were all like
what
and he was like
tucked away rip her in half
[ __ ] her until she bleeds to death and
we were like what are you talking about
man it's like i'm talking about sex sex
she's just regular sex that's
really
[Laughter]
and everybody walked away
i got kicked out of that class a few
times for he pointed me out one time i
was asleep in like the second row yeah
and oh yeah and it's so weird waking up
[Music]
into a situation where everyone's
looking at you yeah because i was asleep
in like the second row and apparently he
was like look at this guy
just sleeping in the second row
probably hung over i had like a like a
wristband on from like the night before
he's like probably look at his wristband
probably hung over right now
and like he's like why don't you get
your buddy up to my friend and like
nudges me and i just like wake up
and he's like and i just hear oh he's
awake and just
a classroom of a thousand people starts
laughing and i'm just like
oh man this is rough feel rough wake up
and now you can't go back to sleep
that's the worst part yeah i can't go
back to sleep
that's the worst that'd actually be
pretty legendary if i didn't
tweeted at me like you complain on every
podcast you know and i thought to myself
do i and i thought you know what [ __ ]
you yeah i do yeah cause that's my brand
[ __ ] right
bitching with griffin yeah
that's my brand okay so i thought about
i said you know what i'm just going i'm
gonna lean into it and put my foot in it
can you imagine if someone said like
bill burr complains too much you're like
that's what he's good at that's what we
do you're good but you're good at when
you complain when you and i i mean who
am i to talk i complain about everything
when you and i complain uh
there's there's purpose it's not just
complaining just to complain i'm just i
have a thing you know as far who knows
fault this is stupid-ass bobby this is
bobby's fault everything is his fault
yeah because he'll come with his thing
you complain like the way he says it and
then all those the hall is like troll
minions you know what i mean they start
to be like yeah you complain i was like
do you listen to tiger belly just all he
does is complain yeah he complains all
the time but all of a sudden i'm in i
own complaining but anyways let me get
back to my complaint
and i got the hot girl who
doesn't want to touch me
and the ugly one wants to [ __ ] ari yeah
she doesn't get a lot of guys yeah yeah
so now i'm in a closet there are
researchers scripts right
with the [ __ ] hot one oh yeah so i'm
tr um we're both on each other's beds
like he's on his bed i'm on my bed with
my girl he's done with his girl and i'm
we're like making out i've never done
anything like that i've had sex with
like three or four girls at the time
maybe four yeah maybe maybe five because
he looked really chewy back then yeah
yeah yeah right he looks good i think
you look better now when you were
younger it was like dora beaker from the
muppets like you look weird yeah yeah
so yeah we're taking out here on the
other bed could you just touch your
shoulder
how about you just touch your shoulder
yeah yeah yeah yeah what if i do
this
i'm just gonna roll the back of my hand
on your on your knee yeah yeah yeah i
was doing drugs i was staying at ari
shafir's old place dude before he
freaking
uh
did that uh epithet for kobe or whatever
he did whatever it's called before he
spoke at his funeral yeah yeah and uh
i got locked out of there dude i had to
climb they have like these communal
gardens or something yeah it's like you
know sometimes
no they don't
they do though they have like there's no
communal cars
no problems
like bro it was insane it was just crazy
yeah yeah i knew it was just a lot bro
you're sweating this is a lot going on
for even somebody that's not i feel like
i almost got wrapped up in one of your
stories it almost happened just right
there bro it almost happened right there
because
it sounded so romantic fantastical that
i was like oh tell me about new york
[ __ ] communal culture at 12th and sea
there's a [ __ ] communal garden or
somebody burned a building down in the
spring
starting to grow dude anyway i had to
jump a fence i just sneak around the
back of his building to get in yeah and
you're trying to do boot camp with
football at the same time it was funny
because while you're getting recruited
they're like
football all the football players we get
an escape we get to leave the military
stuff and go play football and it's like
nice turns out college football sucks
it was way worse than boot camp i was
like let me go back to let me go back to
[ __ ] walking
all
boot camp was at west point was like
walking and standing
now that was the first couple weeks i'm
sure it got harder but i got out of
there how do you before i got hard how
do you just cry
all you have to do is cry
you're six three three hundred pounds
crying they're like all right you're
[ __ ] going home i was like i want to
go home that was really it i remember
the night before boot camp
i was in a hotel like with my parents
because your parents dropped you off at
like 5am or 6am so
i was just laying there with them and i
was like geez this is in a hotel room
and uh
were they supportive did they think this
was a good thing or they were like hey
we don't have to pay for college he goes
right we're so proud so proud
so that was yeah that will come back
with yes
that was the last time they've been
proud of me twice
and both times catastrophic failures
that seem to last about the same amount
dude same amount
and uh
i mean truly i've had six weeks in my
entire life with my parents being proud
but uh
this was very funny so when they drop
you off they you drop they drop you off
in regular clothes and your parents say
goodbye to you and then at the end of
the day there's a parade of all the new
cadets in front of all the parents and
now they see you marching in a uniform
head shaved at the end of the day
so
during that parade i see my mom like
waving a flag like one of those mini
flags and i walked by her and she was
like yes and i was like i'm getting the
[ __ ]
out in one hour
and she literally went like this dude
she goes
she dropped her flag
and what was funny is like while you're
quitting i was still getting letters
from people back home that were like
we're so proud of you this is incredible
and i was like you're already out i'm
out you're already sitting on the couch
i was getting letters from people that
were like we love you we're proud of you
and i was like i'm going to community
college
yeah so when you call your parents like
hey i'm quitting they're coached
by like drill instructors and recruiters
to be like say no say they're literally
not allowed to come home so my parents
when i called them and i was like i'm
coming home i'm [ __ ] quitting they're
like you cannot quit and i was like you
guys are [ __ ] losers
[Music]
you're a [ __ ] teacher mom shut the
[ __ ] up
it was it was really regrettable stuff
dude
it was embarrassing
dude imagine crying on the phone
with your body other dudes crying
waiting to get with your mama
[ __ ] up mom
you [ __ ] you're a loser
in the civil war
actually even though i you know being
enslaved which these has remind us that
we don't say slaves anymore now it's
enslaved that's the pc woke way you have
to say you're enslaved if you say slay
enslav
enslaved n-word enslaved yeah
yeah so now at this point you know
neck bleeding the week before he had
beat me up and now i hate him
and i'm scared like i literally have
like kind of a ptsd kind of a situation
where i'm like shocked by it yeah it's
true this trauma
so when carlos finds out that ahri had
booked the job
in a sketch and we were fighting
he
called you and said hey bro i can't have
you on my show no no no what oh they
just said they brought out the part
he didn't call me he didn't call you oh
he's the worst man he's you know oh yeah
he called you he's like oh yeah man they
just we're at the part it's nothing
so he told me that he had called you and
said hey bro you can't beat up my friend
and all that stuff he he said it's like
hey you got to stop being at my friend
and then later it was like the part was
written out
no he's he'll never oh
so anyway
but did you think that i'm the one
because that's what i asked him to fire
me yeah yeah yeah i wasn't yeah i i want
to let you know right now yeah i wasn't
okay i believe you okay why would i do
that i didn't even know about it wait i
mean if you had questions why would i do
that the answer is clearly this guy just
punched me two times can you please get
him fired
why would i how would i even know that
you got hired all that stuff i don't
know carlo's going hey that guy got a
job in my show you're like hey can you
get them not that
i'm not saying you did yeah yeah yeah
but that that's a that's a that's a
really good way okay didn't do it yeah
all right and so then i was like bobby
got me fired i was like well that's a
line in in comedy where it's like it's
so hard to find jobs you can't [ __ ] with
someone's income
but with their job they're trying to
this career so hard right so and i was
like well i have to punch you down
now the rest was rageful this is like no
no this is the right thing to do yeah
yeah so i'm at the parking lot at the
comedy store
and i just hear
like running like running
you don't think that somebody's going to
do a superman punch from behind
i was talking to dave
i saw bobby
excuse me
or something real calm down yeah yeah
take care of this yeah
he just bobby starts running away i
jumped and hit me from the back
and then i
fell again that was your number one
defensive move okay i'm excited right
now um that's my defensive move
wrestle in college no no
how tall are you six foot three yeah i'm
five four you have us better uh
basically
yeah you're you're one up behind that
plus you're out waving by 50 pounds
okay
so
george you're laughing way too hard at
that you are laughing pretty hard george
give it up
so then i go to the right side of the
room yeah so i go to the cover booth
another cover but i go to the office
yeah to call the police yeah did they
ban you then i think up for a month or
something after that they banned me and
then um yeah they're like you you can't
be beating up bobby three times two is
okay but
the third time yeah we have a no beating
on bobby three times yeah yeah um
and then uh
i was banned and then it started they
like you have to talk to bobby and work
it out
and so i was like fine let's talk yeah
and you're like can i just i'm like fine
okay talk then and this is not what i
wanted i was like then do it yeah but
he's also he does he would also do this
even after he got back in
i'd walk down the hallway and you he
would just say [ __ ]
like he was the dumbest guy in the
[ __ ] building i knew what would
bother you yeah things that he he knew
that would bother me you just you can't
even get a thought together you can't
even speak english do that and you're
born here you're like he would say [ __ ]
yeah to get me riled up and i would just
be like i can't even
come here
i hate this guy
and it was like that for years
in court to be like four people around
you know him and like three other people
talking like what are you doing
listening bobby's lies you're you're
lying about something that's what you do
you lie
so is that just like
you know i'm just trying to conversation
nope not allowed
foozy you ever seen that guy foosey on
youtube uh yeah so anyway i met this guy
one time and honestly i thought he was a
real [ __ ] clown [ __ ]
he just had a really intense ego that's
what i felt like about the young guy and
i think he got he he fraudulently made
some videos that were like you know
watch this butterfly hug this homeless
guy you know yeah i mean you know see
what happens when this seventh when the
seven month old baby crawls past this
homeless guy you know like that those
kind of videos always he did those like
you know
videos that kind of fed into that whole
click baby thing yeah and it was fake
though it was like it was pre-arranged
it was like a thumbnail like this yeah
and it's like i can't believe she said
that yeah you know it's like guess who
gets leprosy and it's just like
[Laughter]
i went out with a girl
in eighth grade who i was like this is
like my
my first girlfriend and i'm so
such a i don't know it's so juvenile i i
feel like there was some like exchange
of like will you be my girlfriend yeah
and she was like i will
that kind of thing i'll do that yeah and
we went to the movies
and i think
maybe one other
one other weekend we did something else
and we hung out at each other's place
couple times this is eighth grade
and
nothing has happened yet like we've
we've held hands we haven't even kissed
yet okay but she's my girlfriend for 8th
graders
two weeks later
her friend
calls me and reads a letter to break up
with me
over the phone you're gonna want to sit
down but she didn't do it she gave her a
friend her friend was like i would call
you to tell you i thought
and you sat next and i sat and listened
to it and she's like i think we're
growing apart i was like what the [ __ ]
we're in eighth grade yeah and also like
nothing's happened yet you ever seen
some weird voodoo [ __ ] down there
yeah i mean i lost my virginity to a 55
year old woman on bourbon street when i
was 16 16 is that legal though did she
did she commit statutory rape or the
eyes of the law it's all good i'm a
survivor but you know what it was great
i feel like those kids have [ __ ] their
teacher i was like no no i was into it
yeah that was great
mark's a survivor i if somebody had to
remind me of that they're like you know
you're a survivor i was like oh i guess
i could use that and make a career out
of it yeah if i was a shittier comedian
yeah but yeah yeah dude that's hilarious
you should write a book i had no idea
maybe i'll do a one-man show i'll call
colin how do i write these yeah 100
colin hope you're listening the last
time somebody's in the studio colin got
covered he's getting better
cq we love you baby i think the lady i
[ __ ] at covet and that was in 2000
yeah yeah
i went upstairs because this is when i
was dating sarah yeah right and she was
upstairs doing some sort of adam i
wanted to [ __ ] her to get back at you
i was like i'm not even into it but i
was like
yeah i think i'll do this
i think i'll do hurt you right after you
broke up i was like i know you still
care yeah oh my god
it's amazing this guy
i love it there was a picture posted of
me kevin hart and this guy too ray from
montreal last year
and uh jewish comic people yeah they
were putting they were all the only ones
so everyone was putting these uh you
know comments under it and my daughter
like
because she's like a [ __ ] she's she's
a ball bust no she goes
she goes oh great you think you're
special now or something like that
and then right below that someone
replies that comment and goes like god
you're such an ugly little [ __ ]
now
uh i then go on a tirade i go over the
radio i give this guy's [ __ ]
twitter or instagram hands shut up i go
adam and i start like even online saying
things like he's in portland i go hey
guess what i'll be in portland in two
weeks i go i'd love you to come find me
and say something like that
and
there's no reply then we do the whole
radio show [ __ ] on this guy soda's
going at him
and then i get a message right back and
i think he goes he goes oh my god dude
i'm such a big fan he goes i am such an
idiot he goes i didn't look at the name
even
he goes i just was defending you i
thought somebody was [ __ ] on you and
i was defending
[Laughter]
my daughter by the way calls me i like
when she finds her excuses to say
something she goes she calls me like
like late night one night and she goes
dad one of your fans just called me a
little [ __ ] on an ugly [ __ ] on the thing
i go i go what she goes yeah and there's
a message that says ugly come by the
fifth tail like stop saying [ __ ]
[Laughter]
one time this kid had a birthday party
at his house right
and uh and his parents got a sauna or
not a sauna what was a
thing of hot water in your yard what's
that thing called
a jacuzzi jacuzzi okay so his parents
got a jacuzzi dude in louisiana first of
all all of louisiana is a [ __ ]
jacuzzi right the entire state is made
out of jacuzzi right like this you could
step in your front yard have you ever
used that on stage you know you ever
said that dude that's hilarious but it's
so
we're all in his yard dude in night it's
95 degrees outside we're sitting in the
middle of a hot yard 90 degree water
right just boiling for my buddy's
birthday party right just [ __ ] making
just buddy soup you know we're just
celebrating this party because his
parents got this [ __ ] jacuzzi
well some kid in our school had learned
how to uh jerk off and the rest of us
had never seen it right
so this dude's like secretly jerking off
under the water you know
and uh
and and this guy was like 30 years old
he shouldn't have been in school anymore
like at a certain this one you could
just stay in school until eventually you
got you know you got a job as like a
janitor or something yeah you know yeah
you come to this like eighth you know
you come to eighth grade or sixth grade
for the 15th time and finally like
you're a [ __ ] janitor you know you're
hired you know you're not in school
you're over here by the brooms you know
and anyway this dude had been jerking
off under the water but nobody knew then
he stood up and started just ejaculating
into the [ __ ] jacuzzi right oh [ __ ]
none of us had ever seen this we didn't
even know this could happen right
so everybody thinks that this guy cj is
melting out of his penis like
like he was just it was gonna keep
happening until he just got smaller and
smaller and smaller yeah and just
disappeared so this kid named will
grabs onto his penis to stop it from
[ __ ] what yeah yeah
and you know that hurts dude if you're
ejaculating if you're spraying out yeah
you gotta especially
yeah and they weren't even that close
they weren't even that good to buddies
you know if a buddy maybe grabs with
your penis with two hands a little
different some guy you don't super know
that well yeah and he didn't have real
strong grip so it was still kind of
happening you know yeah you got to
squeeze at the base
this guy had no yeah he didn't have a
lot
yeah this guy this wheeled kid didn't
have a lot of technique uh excuse me
little semen
[Music]
[Music]
you